join now by the organization
spokesperson Dr Margaret Harris hello to
Dr Harris thank you for joining us on
the program this morning thank you talk
to us about the latest that you're
hearing and the work that you're doing
yes and I think you're illustrating what
kind of work we're having to do and
we'll be doing in future by your
reporting from the refugee camp it's the
immediate needs obviously are to get
people out from under the rubble and to
deal with the the crushed wounds and the
um the immediate damage but there's so
much long-term change to People's Health
just like the gentleman who's found
himself immobile and we are bringing in
a lot of supplies for surgical and
Trauma care but also what you call
assistive Technologies things like
wheelchairs things that can help people
resume their normal their lives as best
as possible with the injuries they've
received
um we've got early damage assessments so
we know that at least 15 hospitals have
been damaged in the area and hundreds of
Health Facilities but it's it's quite
also of course health workers have had
to be repurposed to go and look after
the immediate um knee kids of all the
people who have been injured also to
deal with what they've suffered we've
lost health workers and do to deal with
their families and and all the many
um disturbances in their lives we are
bringing in a lot of supplies we managed
to get suppliers to 16 hospitals in
Northwest Syria on Monday because we had
repurposed supplies that we could get to
them quickly
and uh and we are as I said doing
further and further damage assessments
and working to bring in emergency
medical teams at the request of the
country so that they're the people who
can actually provide the right services
in the right places
yeah I'm reading about three uh charter
flights that should be carrying medical
supplies uh trauma kits Etc they arrived
yet
no not yet so they're in our Dubai Hub
and waiting to go there's stuff exactly
right they're packed with uh 160 metric
tons for the the plan that's planning to
plan for Syria I haven't got an exact
departure time or or where it's going to
yet but as soon as I know we'll we'll
certainly release that information
yeah Syria particularly challenging for
you
indeed but these are areas we've worked
in and Syria I mean we've already had uh
15 million people there who have been
needing Care Help uh who've been in the
dire humanitarian crisis before this
happened and so as as you mentioned
we're saying it's a crisis on a crisis
but I guess if there's any good thing it
does mean we've got teams on the ground
it does mean we have a lot of people who
have been already been repurposed and
can uh have been mobilized to do the
utmost to try to limit the harm if
that's a way of putting it of this
terrible terrible disaster
yeah talk to me about the death child
the latest that we're hearing is almost
9 000 you were predicting up to 20 000.
it's impossible to say at this stage
isn't it
that's right it's impossible to say that
was one of my colleagues who was looking
at what had happened in past
um uh uh earthquakes and disasters of
this nature but it's that's just a very
general thing each disaster is different
and of course the work going on to get
people out uh is extremely important we
won't really know the extent of these
losses uh and for quite some time and
the important thing is to prevent people
who've been injured or who've been
affected by this from also dying so you
have things like babies being born we
saw a baby that was born under the
rubble yesterday babies will be born in
the next few days to people who are
Sheltering in cars who are in dire
situations and that is not a situation
you want a child to be born in people
who've got chronic illness who need
diabetics who need to get their
treatment people who have hypertension
and uh that the stress may lead to heart
attack so all those health Services need
to be provided as quickly and as close
to the people who are currently
suffering
doctor um some modeling that I've seen
um with the help I'm told of the World
Health Organization suggest uh that the
numbers could go up as high as 60 000
deaths is that a number that you would
recognize
so again this is not something we could
say yes or no to uh that uh what our job
is
is to prevent those numbers going as
high as possible by bringing in as
strong and as appropriate and fit for
purpose Health response
yeah and that's as you say will be in
the form of things like medical supplies
etc etc but a lot of the infrastructure
is damaged here as well not just in
southeast turkey but also in Syria what
can you do to help with that
so again what we've found works is to
bring in emergency medical team to
basically come in with their own
infrastructure um with their own skills
their equipment but they have to be the
right teams for the right place so that
both countries have asked us for
specific types of Emergency Medical
Teams and we've put out a call
immediately on Monday and we're bringing
those in uh other things that are needed
so essentially you've got to set up a
system on on the spot like field
hospitals but uh where it is rather
because again exactly as you said the
infrastructure is so damaged you don't
necessarily have a hospital that's
functioning but where infrastructure is
usable it has to be in then you support
as needed as appropriate so that's
exactly why we're doing a damage
assessment to look at what is working
what isn't working what could be put in
place very very quickly to try to
achieve some kind of level of
functioning of a health system
when you say very quickly of course
that's all relative isn't it for
um somebody who is still stuck
underneath Rubble
records show that if we don't find them
today then they're not coming out alive
um
what else do we have to factor into a
timetable over the next few days and
weeks and months and years
exactly
um so for people under the rubble there
is still hope but it does indeed make it
harder because they've suffered from the
dust inhalation they've suffered from
their Crush injuries so they haven't got
the immediate care that could help them
survive this uh but in the mid midterm
or or pretty much the immediate term too
we've got to look at preventing
infectious diseases so again people who
are crowded together in very cold
circumstances
and difficult circumstances whose immune
systems have been under tremendous
stress from what they've experienced and
the grief and the shock and the
uncertainty so there is likely to be a
surge in respiratory infections because
we're quite a lot of respiratory viruses
so all the viruses that we've been
suffering all winter haven't gone away
because of the earthquake we're also
there's a risk because of the damage to
uh the Water and Sewage systems there's
a risk of waterborne infections
such as cholera
we've also got a risk of there's going
to be severe mental trauma so we need to
bring in the psychological psychosocial
support right from the start that's not
a laughter thought that's not a luxury
that has to happen right at the start
and again getting the essential
medicines to the places where people
need them is critical because there are
a lot of people who are on medicines
that if they can't have those medicines
they their their illness that it's
keeping at Bay will return and and could
kill them